[Music]
this thing looks like it slinked
right out of your worst nightmare
with 11 or 12 rows of needle sharp teeth
it's no wonder this creature has been
nicknamed
the vampire fish though it looks like
the worm from the movie tremors
it's a fish called a lamprey people fear
this creature's slimy texture
it's suction mouth and most of all its
concentric circles of teeth
i don't know about you but i wouldn't
want to swim anywhere near that thing
but are these creepy creatures dangerous
what do they eat
and possibly more important are they
capable of killing you
stick around you won't want to miss
these vampires of the deep
a lamprey may resemble an eel's color
and shape
but that's where the similarities end
for one thing
it lacks paired fins and a jaw its
skeleton is made of cartilage instead of
bone
just like a stingray it has seven gill
openings on each side of its head
and smooth scaleless skin and to make
this creature
even crazier it's also a parasite
to feed it attaches itself to other fish
using its specialized
suction mouth and teeth then it uses its
file-like tongue to rasp through the
fish's scales
and feast on its blood and fluids boy
they weren't joking when they called
this thing a vampire fish
good night kids sleep well okay if
lampreys are incredibly dangerous to
fish
should we be scared of them too lampreys
are so destructive that sometimes
only one out of seven fish they attack
will survive
and they're not picky eaters either
preying on all types of fish
ranging from trout to sturgeon but
despite the lamprey's maligned
reputation
it is relatively harmless to humans
according to experiments performed by
wilderness adventurers
it's not likely that a sea lamprey would
attack a human
unprovoked plus there are no reports of
deaths caused by lampreys
so even though they look scary they
won't kill you
but they have hurt some ecosystems the
first documented lamprey was found in
canada's lake ontario in 1835.
by 1921 they had entered lake erie
through the welland canal and lampreys
were established in all
five great lakes by 1938.
they inflicted catastrophic damage to
native lake trout and whitefish
in lake superior michigan and huron
this happened because female lampreys
can lay up to 100
000 eggs the primary method of
controlling the lamprey population
is a lamprecite called tfm
tfm kills lamprey larvae with little or
no
impact on other fish and wildlife
and that's not the only way to keep
their population in check
in some places lampreys are considered a
delicacy
many european countries capture lampreys
and use them in a variety of dishes
can i interest you in some lamprey pie
no you cannot lampreys have remained
largely unchanged for more than
340 million years and they have survived
at least
four major extinction events so no
matter how much you loathe these
parasitic creatures
they're going to survive oh yay
sucking blood and having terrifying
teeth is what lampreys do
and that's what makes them crazy
[Music]
creatures